[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of episode 7 of severance this
one is directed by ben stiller he had
done the first couple episodes and it's
written by helen lay so we jumped right
where we left off from last episode
where mark is with ragabai and she's
saying a lot of important stuff here
like she's like i put that chip in your
head i'm the only one who can deactivate
it to mark she says and she brings up
how it's so infantilizing this process
of severance but she then reflects and
says that he is just a baby though his
innie because he's only been you know
severed for two years which is
interesting because again going to all
the theories and themes about you know
them being like children these innies
and the different lengths they've been
to especially with like an irving who's
been severed for a while and that he's
seeing black goo and different side
effects so it's really just kind of
falling into that umbrella i love some
of the writing here where she's like
maybe he dreams every day about clawing
to the surface talking about mark's
innie and says you brought him into this
world without his permission based on
your own desire for emotional
convenience so this is when he says back
i'm not a bad person and she says i
think you want to do what's right for
both of you so it's really interesting
her saying that it makes you kind of
question even his choice to even be
severed and anybody's choice to be
severed but also this is really kind of
making you think about the possibilities
for this show because you know the
characters we know how different their
audis could be than their innies are
similar but we know mark has a lot of
similarities and what he at the end of
the day is doing is right he's trying to
go for the just cause he is a good guy
like he says but it makes me wonder like
when we get to know helly's audi more
what is she going to really be like so i
think it's it's very cool how this show
has so much possibilities having these
kind of two versions of people but at
the same time similarities inside of
them so greaner shows up at this point
and like i predicted last review he
wasn't going to make it alive i mean
there was no way they were going to get
that situation of greener following them
and not having to kind of get rid of his
character and ragabay hits him in the
back of the head with a bat but this
leads to the big moment where she gives
mark greener's security card and takes
pd's phone so this is huge because just
the any of mark getting security card is
a huge huge advantage for the mdr
department now what was interesting to
me is miss selvig aka harmony sees mark
throw his clothes into the garbage and
she notices it's at an earlier time than
he usually goes to his garbage so i am
very convinced that miss selvig went
back and grabbed those clothes because
she is gonna need them to kind of prove
what happened to grainer here from
through mark so there's a lot going on i
liked with miss selvik here and the side
of harmony outside of work which we're
gonna get to so this episode is crazy
for the character of milchik it's my
favorite episode of the character of
milchik and he's really just in deep
[ __ ] this episode and he's doing serious
damage control he's greeting mark he's
greeting dylan the same way he had told
mark to greet heli after her incident
with the big fake smile and now he's
saying new protocol i'm going to walk
you to your department from the elevator
and we see that last episode they
installed those doors so they're
literally locked in here in the mdr
department which is just crazy and it's
crazy the whole information that changes
everything and really sets up to make
this episode really interesting is dylan
now knowing that he has a kid outside of
work and that dylan will eventually
reveal to the mdr department that they
can on and off people severing outside
of work which is huge now remember
milcheck does mention a dylan she has
not told cobell about any of this yet
because she's super stressed but he
doesn't want to open that can of worms
with her either because again he doesn't
know how she's going to react and this
will be something later on when dylan
says to mill check like you know if you
want to you know rap me out i'll go
gladly to miss colbert as well but
milcheck knows like he doesn't really
want her finding out about all this
because this is not looking good for him
now my one moment i kind of was a little
annoyed at with the writing was when
dylan asked milcheck when they first
were together in lumen he says is the
boy that he saw my son why didn't
millcheck just lie to him here i thought
it was strange that he wouldn't kind of
make up some kind of story about who
that kid really was to at least give him
some doubt he confirmed it so that will
give him no doubt and he's just gonna
want to know more about his son so i
thought that was strange that he
wouldn't lie about that just to kind of
cool dylan off it was a very stupid
decision by milchik which felt out of
character but you see he brings up
special perks to dylan that he's going
to try to get him because he knows that
is what dylan lives off here at lumen
he's a guy who loves his perks it gets
him distracted from what's really going
on but the brilliant thing about this
episode with dylan's character is the
perks aren't working on him anymore he
is awakened so this is where i want to
go to a fascinating scene before we come
back to what's happening at lumen is
with kobo who milchik's trying to get on
the phone with she's not answering she
didn't come in today he's telling her
greiner didn't come in today but she's
too busy playing nanny of the year for
devon and there's a lot of mystery to
why she's really investing her time in
devon we get the answers here which i
love but we learn a lot too now devin
brings up what she experienced last
episode where she saw the senator and
his wife gabby and that gabby didn't
remember her and then she says to ms
selvik you know my husband works at loom
and mark i wonder if they could sever
people outside of lumen if they ever do
that and then she's like you know what
if you had a baby and then didn't want
to know who you had it with and what was
fascinating is the lion harmony says
back saying i wouldn't remember clark
gable if i hadn't given birth so she's
throwing a clark gable reference out
there right now he was famous from 1931
his career to 1961. so
clearly the theories that you know
harmony is just a version of the
original let's say harmony that is this
chip that she has a chip in her head
continuing that that theory of severance
where they want to extend life right
that if she's referencing something like
that that brain part of her that chip is
an older woman and it's way older than
the body we're seeing of harmony and
that she's probably moved on to this
body and also remember the way patricia
arquette is playing harmony she's
talking like someone from back in the
day you know she's not talking like
someone today so it makes complete sense
so those little lines like that are huge
hints at what's really going on and when
we saw in her shrine those old childhood
pictures of her you know those were old
pictures so that's got to be the
original form the original body that
gets just keeps moving on through life
through the chip it's really her being
way older than she actually appears
that's what i obviously think is going
on now that that reference confirmed it
for me and then what's huge when you
look back at the big reveal the end of
this episode is this line where harmony
asks devon if mark talks about his wife
and then asked as mark ever thinks he
sees her so this tells you why the main
reason she's there with devin she's
checking in that mark isn't figuring
things out about his wife who we learn
now is miss casey so
gemma is miss casey he literally works
with his wife and what's crazy is the
visual cue they had to this was i think
episode or two ago when she's coming out
of the break room and he's passing her
and they stop and they have this like
very knowing look at each other so you
wonder like okay that was a little hint
and now looking back at that scene you
kind of see there's more importance to
that relationship because they've done a
good job of not showing them together
much to kind of not make it obvious and
it makes sense now exactly why harmony
would be asking devon these questions so
we get another great scene where back at
lumen we're getting our first experience
of the mde experience the music dance
experience it's five minutes right and
you see
that mill checks like it's a hard day
for all of us and that's where helly
kind of takes a pause like hard for you
but he doesn't explain why but clearly
because you know he found out about
grainer he's got the stuff he's not
telling his cobell everything's just
going out of control for him now it's
interesting helly chooses the maracas
but irv says back to that you should
have gone with the cassanets i'm sure
that's gonna be a line that's important
later on
that will make sense later on maybe
we'll see that when we get an erv
episode eventually why he would say that
because it's such a random line and i
love that if you look at the list of
music choice they have there's hoot and
toot and country and exciting rap i
thought that was really funny but of
course helly chooses defiant jazz that's
exactly what heli is but what you gotta
understand about milkshakes here is he's
encouraging everyone even not just helly
but everyone to you know take advantage
of this five minute dance this perk you
can all see so the point of that is that
it's showing dylan would normally be the
one to run up even if helly won it he's
still gonna go up there and dance and
see all the perks and see what is this
and he doesn't hear this isn't the dylan
we know again he's different now the
best part is the way that milchik
milkshakes dancing and when he goes up
and he's dancing to dylan it just
reminded me of jackass with the party
boy dance so funny and you see though
dylan's about just like explode he
eventually does because again he's
thinking about his son now he's gonna
want to know what's his name like he
says to milchik and then he freaking
bites him but that's where you see what
i was talking about where milchik says
him reporting this to miss cobell and
he's like okay yeah you want to go
together but that's where you see he's
got something on milchik now about him
coming out of work and doing this with
no approval but my favorite part of the
episode that just made me laugh a lot is
when milchik's leaving and he turns
around and he says the music dance
experience is officially canceled i
thought that was just again one of those
funny moments the show kind of throws in
in this crazy world we're in but this is
where dylan drops a huge bomb and tells
the group like milkshake told him not to
do not to tell any colleagues about this
huge information that they can turn us
on and off outside of work and that's
going to clearly make all of them really
want to rebel now and again this just
adds to more of my fascination of like
them talking about where hell is like if
they can wake us up on the outside
what's to stop us from doing it to
ourselves but where i feel like a helly
audi might get in their way i'm excited
to see kind of conflict like that
conflict of someone versus themself
another thing i didn't really wasn't
crazy about the writing though just
little nitpicks but when they asked mark
do you know where the security office is
he says pd showed it to me during a fire
alarm last year okay so for me with the
writers it's like okay use your pd out
you know don't do that again you get one
right if they keep doing that we're all
petey showed me once like that's too
easy you know so it's a little bit of a
cheat but i'm cool with it because it's
the first time but never again don't
just keep you know justifying how he
would know where the security office is
by just saying oh pd showed me once you
know we don't want to get in that habit
so it's cool we're already getting these
visual answers right like mark and helly
in the security office you see this
panel and there's a bunch of knobs and
switches but what's interesting is
you're seeing different labeled
departments and they're all small
departments you're seeing some
departments are just two people some of
four some with six they're not this huge
thing and like they're even saying
there's not all these security guards
there's a lot of illusion going on with
lumen and the tension in this episode
just ramps up when kobold gets in the
building and when we're also seeing that
irv is going to find bert so that's
where this really starts to shine and
ben stiller is just showing how amazing
he is at doing suspense in the show now
what got me excited for the future of
the show is when kobo is informed by
natalie that the board found out that
grayner is dead and she's learning about
it here as well but she demands to them
literally to show her findings that
reintegration is real and that she wants
it in person so they finally agreed to
it and they said in a week they'll do it
at the egan family gala this is going to
be huge i think i'm excited for this
scene i'm excited to see members of the
board i do believe my theory is that we
only got two episodes left i think this
will be something we see in the finale
and it's going to be the thing that sets
up the season two plot line remember
season two has already been approved so
this story is gonna go on for a bit it's
gonna set up more of the board verse
harmony but also the board being more
central characters i think for season
two and the story of you know them
finding out about reintegration it's
going to be interesting now also dylan
steps up here when helly and him and
mark are talking about how they're going
to go about this with the switches that
he's going to turn the switches off stay
after work and he's really pushing like
i can do this two-man job when you see
writing like that i am gonna predict
that dylan is a goner we got his little
story here about him finding out his kid
so we knew more about him before we
would lose him now he's gonna do the
hero thing so i think that this is it
for dylan and that's going to be one of
the big deaths and again i think which i
already appreciate too that bertner
would have some kind of tragedy i think
what we're seeing in this episode which
we're going to go to right now is that
you know bert's not going to make it so
it's heartbreaking right winner sees
bert because they're giving him a
retirement party irv knows what this
means that they're gonna kill bert and
just the burt audi video it hits so hard
because his audi doesn't know who irv is
so it's tragic him hearing burnt out
even say like i don't really know you
guys i don't really have memories of any
of you but you know thanks for your time
and this is so hard and gut-wrenching to
irv and i love john detero's moment here
where he yells at milch he's like are we
all just going to let bert die and mild
chicks like burt's audi is retiring
it'll happen to you someday and the best
moment is when irv says you smug mother
effort you're not severed no one cripped
your memories out like they never
existed because again that's how he's
feeling now watching this video of
burt's audi and we see this bird
situation was exactly the thing to break
a character like irv it's great
character writing because irv we saw
earlier this season is the one who was
always obeying everything he was a man
of company and now he is the rebel he
literally is going to have the line
let's burn this place to the ground it's
a great turn for a character and it's
earned but i think that is where bert
served his purpose now and that's why i
don't think burt will survive this
clearly and that's what's cool too like
i'm you know i'm not sure about any of
this and they could all survive but i do
think it's cool at the show they do also
because it's such a mystery show and we
don't know every location and who works
here we don't even know the board
members they can introduce a lot of new
characters and have kind of maybe heli
mark and irv be the central characters
and add in new ones each season while we
lose some i think that works for this
type of show so this big moment at the
end is we've seen this whole episode
that mark is blowing in with alexa now
he's drinking heavy here and he rips his
picture of his wife gemma in front of
her yikes i hope alexa tells devin that
he's in this bad of a state but he's
clearly blown it with alexa here someone
would be really good for him but we see
this big reveal that gemma is miss casey
and like i said i think the biggest hit
was when they passed each other walking
out of the break room a couple episodes
if you watch that scene back it's a
really cool reveal i haven't been on top
of the reddit for this show so i can't
say if i've seen any theories on it but
i haven't so it shocked me i was like
that's awesome i did not think of that
at all i'm sure people have though and
i'm probably gonna hear that in the
comments but i think it's a great twist
and that's the bittersweet thing about
reddit too sometimes for shows like this
i do like reading theories and i don't
because if someone gets it right it's
not as like that exhilarating feeling
like you know spoilers right now if you
haven't seen westworld season one i'm
gonna say spoilers so skip ahead like 15
seconds but in the middle of westworld
when they revealed you know bernard was
a robot that was the biggest twist ever
but i hadn't read any theories so i i
like that magic too and i don't want to
lose that for a show like this so it's
tough but anyway after that tangent i'm
giving this episode 9.3 this is back to
quality severance for me the last two
episodes i was i liked but i didn't
think were as good as the beginning of
the season this to me was a banger i
really enjoyed it and it really pushed
the plot along had some exciting moments
and we learned a lot of information here
i would argue this is the episode we
learned the most information with the
less new questions but more info so that
should satisfy a lot of people and i do
like that the show seems like it
definitely has a long end game here a
good plan coming out here because
there's so much more for us to learn as
well we only got two episodes left so
i'm sure these are going to be
absolutely crazy and i'm excited to see
what goes on so let me know what you
guys think did you like this episode
your theories anything you want to say i
love to hear it and please like i said
if you subscribe it helps me in so many
ways so please subscribe so you don't
miss one of my review of severance i do
other shows as well movie reviews
celebrity interviews please follow me at
steve varley show on twitter instagram
and tick tock for more of me and i'll
see you next time